it's so wonderful to see you both yeah
just stay like that mary hollis
i want introduction to canada sorry hi
it's the canadian way it's getting away
uh
watching this show i had no idea you
could combine
two genres like that and make it so
brilliant congratulations to both of you
i
absolutely loved it what was it like for
you to watch the series for the first
time annie
[Music]
it was you know very exciting this is a
show that we've
we've been working on in um in randolph
massachusetts
throughout the pandemic um so
you know it's always it always kind of
gets your nerves going when it's
something that's just been
between a small group of people and now
it's being sent out into the world and
it is such
a it's a show unlike anything i've seen
before so
it's a big risky thing but i'm so proud
of it i'm so proud of the cast and the
crew and
and i'm excited to see what happens i
think
i watched it i just i i cried actually
because
first of all we did we were um lucky
enough to get to go to work during a
pandemic
um and i got to work on a show that i
really really care about and i think
um is going to speak to a lot of people
um but i also got to work with my best
friend annie murphy
we weren't best buds before we started
no we were
enemies we made up we passed things up
hi canada i'm america's sweetheart
no i think i i cried but i also i
thought um because
i think annie could echo this too um
seeing a show like this on the page
that's never been done this way this
genre bending
i i think we were all really glad to see
that it worked
that leads the story in the
you know in the single cam so the world
have to
talk to each other and the women are out
there you know suffering the
consequences of all these men who are
trying to constantly burn our houses
down
so it's beautiful it's so well done and
annie for you to go from alexis rose you
took a total 360 turn in this series i
mean
what made you want to do it was it the
accent was it going to a dark place
what was it i got it real thing for a
good worcester accent
yeah um no
i mean i think i wanted to
show myself prove to myself that i could
do something different than
my like beloved alexis rose but i'd been
doing
alexis for six years and i was like oh
god can i do anything else and then
this character came along which was just
she couldn't be further from alexis
and so i knew it was going to be really
scary and
a big challenge but um i was so excited
to
to take it on mm-hmm and mary hollis
your character patty the neighbor
i'm not sure about her yet but how does
she play into allison's life is she
does she kind of care for her yeah i
think
they have they're they're two women who
exist in kevin's universe
um they're both equally dismissed and
overlooked they just don't always
recognize that i think also they've been
pitted against each other for 10 years
deciding that under kevin's sort of rule
in the sitcom they are they're too
different to be friends
um you know allison is so completely
optimistic
and things of a life beyond the one that
they've got and patty is so completely
complacent
it seems that they just they can't find
a way to understand they'd ever get
along
until the end of our our first show
where when given a little bit of space
without that canned laughter and that
hamster wheel of the sitcom
they actually are two women who get to
talk to each other and i think it's the
beginning of
um kind of exploring how when women
do that when they show up for each other
and try to help each other out that you
know
a lot of a lot of things can happen
sometimes right um
some sometimes it's not all good because
we're so powerful
yeah that is so true uh but even
when he watches allison like you said
she's you know she's thinking positively
but
here's kevin and alexis uh i mean i mean
allison the fact that she's trying to
not make herself a priority and she's
doing everything for kevin i mean what
do you want
people to get out of this series
um i think
valerie armstrong who created the show
and mario hollis and i have all talked
about it and
we think that if this
show can help someone feel
like they're not alone to feel like
they've been seen
to feel like maybe they can make some
small positive changes to better their
life for themselves
doesn't have to be murder we don't need
to go that far not condoning that
but if we can if we can do those things
for even
one person i think we'll all feel that
this show has been
a very big success mm-hmm i think
post-painting
two people were you know kind of forced
to like spend way more time with their
partners than maybe usual because nobody
got to leave the house
so i i watch i watch the show and go i
feel seen
and also like you don't have to be with
the person you're with we don't want you
to kill them
but yeah you don't have to be with the
person that you're with and you can live
the life that you want to
never do like that a lot of women are
going to be able to relate to allison
right like there's just
there's something so profounding about
this character that is just going to
speak to a lot of people
um annie uh is there a shit's creek
movie that's happening
did you convince dan is it are you
filming now
like listen to some canadian love here
right now
there is and i will be playing alexis
rose
we'll be stepping in she will be playing
david and alexis
in a crazy twist of fate she's just that
good
um i was gonna ask the same question if
you've heard anything
from dan about a movie dad come on
man make it happen we need this in our
lives we need it we need it
but uh congratulations to both of you
you guys are amazing and i can't wait
for everyone to see this series because
it's going to speak to them on so many
different levels so
thank you thank you thank you for
talking to you on youtube bye